so it's definitely happening we're  making a record  oh no i i promise it's gonna be a hit  hey no man thank you what's up my man i  heard about your record deal dawg you  gonna keep it real now right right  you're gonna stay true to the roots  right you're gonna you're gonna let dog  your boy your boy dwayne dwayne  washington  ramsey junior high hey yo if it ain't  craig the man little y'all  homie you remember me i'm teresa because  you're gonna keep it real yeah  definitely gonna keep it real man so  what yeah what up it's my favorite craig  i-i don't know you man you don't know me  is that how it's gonna be craig no i  really don't know you  you changed are you good you good steak  craig's phone  hey youngblood my girls take care of you  you you taking me oh all right all right  [Music]  hello quinn's phone is for you brother  oh thanks man thanks  all right hello yeah  it fell through it's not happening  damn man nah it's all right  thanks anyway sorry everybody  damn  you